how everyone's Gerry on my chest cube
another five-minute game okay we have a
game against 23:17 hg CP and then a
bunch of numbers
alright so Knight f3 how can we maybe
mix some things up in this game okay
that trump offski attack that's uh
certainly different okay that's a good
thing I'm going to react to that with
just some established pawn in the center
and now how to recapture I'm gonna go
I've played this variation before with
these pawns staggered in this way and
I'm gonna still go with trying to get my
Bishop outside of my pawn chain so my
doubled pawns I don't know that that's
really gonna turn out to be too much of
a liability I do consider my
LightSquared Bishop to be expendable so
I'm not too worried if it if it gets
captured for if there's a bishop for
Bishop exchange or a bishop for net
exchange what do I want to do with this
guy do I really want to play this
advanced my opponents gonna be playing
Bishop to g2 I'm gonna go with Knight d7
instead I want to be able to maintain my
d5 pawn if it comes under fire and I'm
I'm anticipating that it will come under
fire so how can i maybe prep that how
about I actually tuck my Bishop back I
think eventually the White Knight is
gonna play to h4 anyhow and so I want to
be able to maybe recapture in this
direction if that is to occur and then
even maybe play f5 after my Bishop has
been captured c6 is another possibility
and I'm not so sure that there's a
better Square for my Bishop than d6 so I
think I'm gonna be going there next
other moves to maybe be considering is
just King side castling although I think
I might want to hang hold off on that
for a little bit and maybe please is
there something with maybe a five a four
I don't know if I want to play c5 just
yet I want to see how my opponent maybe
puts pressure on my d5 pawn
so why is white not moving what are they
considering or maybe have they logged
off hopefully they didn't
what is there to even do on the white
side just castle right castling is
something that you're gonna have to do
so you might as well do it right away or
maybe pawn to c4 is that being
considered right now hmmm what else is
there
connect the Knights Knight d2 I don't
think Knight c3 is a good option at all
you don't really want to obstruct your C
pawn and it seems as though white has
logged off I'm losing faith no okay
they moved they moved okay so they have
not logged off they were just going into
a a deep think they're all right so what
have I accomplished in the meantime with
my thinking here I guess just Bishop
Bishop out and now get ready to Castle
um I want to reserve this option that's
why I'm holding off on c6 or c5 yeah so
let's just castle if I'm able to open up
the C file my bishop is already in a
position where it's striking at that
point and I think I might want to do
something that's a little bit ugly
looking and it involves this f5 advance
really really blocks in my bishop but it
comes with the purpose of preventing
this pawn advance by white the pawn to
e4 so he looks like a really ugly piece
and maybe I could eventually trade it
off somehow if white plays h4 it may
eventually be looking to press h5 and
then my bishop would be trapped
but that knight on f3 would have to have
first moved so that the the White Queen
could be supporting that h5 square so
certainly something to be aware of I'm
not too afraid of a knight h4 move okay
c4 there comes I want to support my
Center and be in the position to
recapture in this direction recapturing
like this would really make my C excuse
my F pawns really ugly looking I want to
prevent b4 and I'm also looking to clamp
down with a 4 in May
the a and B ponds for white look a
little bit awkward so I'm gonna
reposition my bishop
so that pawn to c4 excuse me White's
pawn to c5 advance doesn't come with
tempo and that Queen move is a bit
awkward because I could always do this
move my bishop is is doing what it's
hitting the Queen and I'm actually a bit
more inclined to be making this move
right now with the follow up being
capturing on e3 and I think it's
important to be capturing on that square
because okay Wow let's take this first
okay so white isn't a pin how can I
piled up on that whitey for pawn this is
my first thought do I have any second
thoughts how about maybe playing my
Bishop here okay I give up my dark
square bishop but my Queen would be in a
pretty good position I'm gonna go for it
looking to just exchange some pieces and
what else I'm just really trying to work
on this pin okay actually I'm starting
to actually hang want to hang on to my
darks for a bishop now seeing that
there's two pieces of greater value on
this diagonal if he five I'm going to
tuck my bishop back
maybe I should capture no I'm gonna
retreat here let's see let's see what
white wants to do I'm getting ready to
maybe press this this move at some point
I'm not quite sure I want to I want to
retain some flexibility here and I
actually wow this is very surprising but
I actually am decide who has a time
advantage so I have the bishop pair I'm
not too concerned about Knight takes
bishop here and my first thought is to
do this c5 advance but there's
additional pressure being placed on d5
because of that Knight move the bishop
on g2 is indirectly putting pressure on
it so I could do this move is I don't
know what the follow-up would be if the
Queen just played too
c22 get out of that pen what else
actually how about Queen b6 Queen b6
looks like it might be pretty good I'm
gonna go for it
yeah Queen b6 is getting ready to win
upon on d4 and c5 would be a blunder
because of just Queen takes pawn it
might be tempting to let's say take take
on that square with the knight but I
don't think that that's best so is there
anything better than anything better
than what what do I want to do here hmm
okay White's getting ready to play c5
and that's gonna really change the pawn
structure and I'm now all of a sudden
having to fight back with time so I
don't know if that was a great decision
Queen b6 unfortunately what about f6 now
I'm not like an f6 either um I'm gonna
try and tolerate a knight on d6 yeah I
mean I'm gonna try to tolerate that
night there and I could maybe get rid of
it with my dark square bishop at some
point my bishop could maybe come back
there okay let's go here first so knight
Knight on d6 it's very deep in my
position I'm not quite sure where it
would go to from there however I could
also think about Knight okay I'm gonna
capture towards the center yeah towards
the center otherwise I might have to
worry about this guy getting pressure so
I could do one of these Knight b6 to ca
to get rid of a knight that would end up
on that square so let's go with this
move first I'm welcoming a knight
exchange I think I do better okay I
think I go with let's get my queen here
first I don't know if I want to go with
the knight Knight to c8 move I think my
Knights gonna be better placed here I do
also have to worry out worried for watch
out for my f6 square so my knight on
this square might be a good thing to
have let's go with this
that actually might be a bit inaccurate
the bishop could take the night and now
I have to worry about my c7 square uh-oh
I'm gonna have to work with it I want to
play rook here I think followed by
Bishop f8
that's my plan yeah that's it that's as
far as I'm taking this right now okay
let's go with ya let's go with this move
yeah okay I want to I want to watch out
for what do we want to watch out for
okay maybe that wasn't the greatest move
there for me okay I could just take here
and then play my rook to c6 I have to
I'm gonna certainly have to defend quite
a bit and I'm I'm glad I took a peek at
my time because I'm down to 22 seconds
so 96 I'm gonna play rook c6 yeah I'm
gonna go with this rook takes rook pawn
takes rook if Knight takes pawn then I
would play rook b6 I just have to I have
to defend I do want to still get my
bishop to f8 my bishop to f8 and then
get my king closer I'm a my king to
eventually gobble up the deep on and I
think I'm gonna be able to do that now
my king is just in time maybe rook h4 I
should be able to win this now I'm gonna
be winning upon here let's go with this
actually first I don't want that rook to
get to the seventh rank I think that was
an important move to be making and I
could just watch my seventh rank and
hopefully just move fast I have to throw
in some pre moves and I'm gonna go after
I'm gonna go after the d5 pawn next so I
have to throw that in and then capture
and actually I should just be gone for
this there we go
another primo this is a
what do we have this is gonna be oh wow
Miller ty came down to a second okay um
that was pretty wild let me just go back
for a second
what was this saw this was the Trump
house key attack what else do we have it
seems a bit awkward to do this
particular move but I think it's a maybe
important what we whites uh getting
ready to press for with that efore I
think just playing f5 to restrain that
is purposeful so that's kind of why I
did that I know my bishop starts to look
very ugly but it could always again get
active by way of h5 I don't know what
other points they are to make I think
actually my decision to play actually
Queen to b6 as if it was a poor one and
maybe even my bishop going back to f6
you know subjecting it to an eventual e5
with tempo that's I don't know that
seems maybe like I could have improved
in that in that way as well and so yeah
Queen Queen to b6 is really starting to
be a bit troublesome for me but I guess
I was able to defend just just in time
to be able to get my my bishop to that
f8 square I have to watch out for the
the white rooks invading on c7 and what
else so we were pretty much just in
blitz mode at this point I know I'm I've
been defending for like a series of
moves but fortunately I'm gonna be able
to play Bishop f8 and then win upon and
I think this is actually the last point
to make really before we just really got
crazy is if I were to have taken let's
say pawn takes pawn the white rook could
have given check on c7 and then maybe
maybe picked off my f7 pod and that's
something that I kind of just wanted to
avoid so that's why I did the rook b6
move this is going to assure me just
being upon up if it were to get to a
King and pawn endgame and then we were
just rattle
all these moves and time pressure but
that's all for this video as always I
hope you're able to take something away
from it take care bye